yes
then allow me to update you on the
latest trips that other college members
have been undertaking to coordinate our
response to russia's invasion of ukraine
for example hrvp
joseph bohel and commissioner valhalla
are in moldova since yesterday where
they met a president maya sandhu and
announced support for the country
commissioner linda chich is also in
moldova today after visiting poland with
commissioner yuan sun
yesterday
commissioner johan sun herself was in
romania and slovakia earlier this week
assessing the situation
at the border
and furthermore vice president sukinas
is in austria today and will be
in the hungarian ukrainian
border area
tomorrow
and commissioner borton is visiting
estonia latvia and lithuania today and
tomorrow to discuss cyber security and
disinformation
you will find more details on these
trips in today's daily news
then let me remind you that the home
affairs ministers are meeting today
and will discuss the commission's
proposal to activate the temporary
protection directive in order to help
those fleeing putin's war
the ministers will also discuss the
governance of the schengen area and the
progress made on the new pact on
migration and asylum
commissioner eva yuansan is attending
this meeting on behalf of the commission
and she will participate in the press
conference for seen
at the end of the meeting as usual we
would appreciate if you could reserve
your questions on these issues for that
press conference
and with this the floor is yours
for questions
so let me go to uh the interaction
platform mindaugus you have the floor
hello good afternoon thank you for this
opportunity eric my name is mundo guest
locals i'm from lithuanian national
radio and television i have a question
on ukraine's admission to the eu i'm
sure you had this question before but
just to clarify so from what i've been
hearing commission's assessment usually
takes a year or more but if there's a
political will for example expressed by
the heads of eu member states
to do these assessments more quickly is
it possible to make this procedure
shorter and how
short could it be so that's my question
thank you very much
thank you min nagas in fact president
vanderlian at her press conference
uh this morning um in romania in romania
um got a similar question and i can
refer you to um her statement
um
and i quote there is no doubt that uh
these brave people and she was referring
to
the ukrainian people who defend our
values with their lives belong in the
european family
and indeed president zielenski sent a
letter on ukraine's application
by that he has set a process in motion
and this we will be discussed
with the member states
right now our focus
is on ending this horrible war and of
course before the strategy started we
already had very strong economic ties
with ukraine we will strengthen them
further and we are working on connecting
ukraine to our european electricity grid
this should happen in the following
weeks
we are in this together and we will
accompany ukraine in this process with
determination and with unity and
solidarity so i think the key message uh
here mindaugus is
that
we acknowledge the fact that president
zielinski's letter has set a process in
motion and that the first stage of this
is a discussion to be had among
the leaders of the european union
um right are there
other questions on uh the enlargement
related aspects
of this file um let's
no less let's do this differently
because i don't think it will be
manageable
there are too many hands raised we will
take the questions one by one like we
did on tuesday uh or on monday and see
um and see who needs to come up
david
you have the thought
yes uh thank you eric
i have
a question on the
open access to information if i may
um and the apparent
violation of article 11 of the lisbon
treaty charter
on fundamental freedoms
this says that everyone has a right of
freedom of expression
that right shall include freedom to hold
opinions to receive and impart
information
and ideas without interference by public
authority
and regardless of frontiers
um
the ukraine is applied to membership
russia
is a potential member
of the european house according to
community principles uh schumann made
clear on the 9th of may 1950
so i'm wondering how you
deal with the apparent violation of this
article of the
the charter of the in the lisbon treaty
thank you very much um we definitely uh
believe that there are uh sound uh legal
grounds and political ground for the
decision that has been taken
and i will call johannes
to the podium on this
yes thank you eric thank you david i
believe you referred to the sanctions
that were adopted
two days ago and were published
yesterday
against russia today and sputnik
the transmission broadcasting in or
directed at the european union is
suspended
this is an exceptionally targeted and
temporary measure taken in a very
specific unprecedented context
i can remind that the sanctions cover
all means for transmission and
distribution
cable satellite iptv platform websites
and apps
state-sponsored propaganda and this
information spread by russia today and
sputnik are an essential and
instrumental tool in bringing forward
and supporting russia's aggression
aggression against ukraine this is
quoted from the decision
this constitutes a significant and
direct threat to the eu's public
order and security
in view of the gravity of the situation
in response to russia's actions
destabilizing the situation in ukraine
it was necessary and consistent
consistent with fundamental rights and
freedoms to dispense suspended
activities of russia day in sputnik in
the european union and also that was a
quote from the decision which i slightly
simplified and i'm happy to
give you the direct quote
which refers exactly
to what you what you're rising
um
where it says it's consistent with the
fundamental rights and freedoms
recognized in the charter fundamental
rights in particular the right to
freedom of expression and information as
recognized in our ticket 11 thereof to
introduce further restrictive
restrictive measures to urgently suspend
the broadcasting activities of such
media outlets in the union or directed
at the union
thank you very much johannes
next question
erisa
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
robin
robin we have a problem with your mic
source
go ahead
press speak
and ask your question
[Music]
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
swift
yes please
we bonjour
let me introduce myself as i'm new here
my name is bianca rotien i'm
correspondent for global global is the
largest tv network in brazil
and of course my question is related to
brazil brazil
if you if you is it related to brazil
and the ukrainian crisis or just brazil
because we're going to deal with
ukrainian crisis first and then with any
other issues brazil related to ukraine
okay then go ahead yes brazil yesterday
voted for the u.n resolution
but criticized the
undiscriminated sanctions
against russia
and the brazilian president jaipur sonar
who visited
president vladimir putin just a week
before the invasion he said this week he
would remain
neutral in this conflict so i would like
to ask you how does the eu
see his position and how
it could affect the relations between
brazil and european union and including
the trade agreement with mercosu
thank you
nebila
hello and
[Music]
thanks for your question first of all
let me
go back to the u.n uh resolution outcome
of yesterday which i think
as you know the u.n
general assembly adopted a resolution on
the aggression against ukraine by an
overwhelming majority of
141 in favor
two and through five against so this is
uh this decision is clear and the world
has issued a risk resounding
condemnation of illegal unprovoked
attacks of a sovereign
state
um as regards to
your question um the vast majority of
latin and caribbean countries have
condemned russia's invasion
of ukraine and they stand on the right
side of history for a sovereign free
nation against the force of tyranny
threatening the international order and
the u.n vote of yesterday shows the
world has issued a resounding
condemnation of the illegal
unprovoked attacks of a sovereign state
now
countries that have criticized uh the
russian invasion you know that are
mexico chile colombia costa rica
argentina
guatemala honduras and ecuador in the
caribbean and the main uh
regional organization caricom has been
very clear
on this as well as uh
have a number of countries in the
national capacity and including benice
berbados
and
that's what i can say in in at this
point uh when it comes to mercosur uh
this is something that is not for for me
yeah thank you um i i would say that
look we have a very specific
uh emergency uh to deal with
um which is uh the uh russian invasion
of ukraine
the european union it's taking its
responsibilities when it comes
to this conflict and
what needs to be done to respond to it
we welcome the support that is provided
by many of our close allies and partners
such as the united states the united
kingdom
canada japan korea
switzerland norway
and many other countries also in the
western balkans etc
on these on these issues
but ultimately it is up to each country
to
decide what is its uh what is its
position we
have trade relations with with brazil
that is a completely different chapter
okay we continue um
it's on energy
energy in ukraine now we're still we're
we deal with ukraine
if it's the european union
in ukraine you can you can go ahead
if it's a security of supply
for yeah
anything is it with ukraine today okay
it's just a short question am i go ahead
propose
on europe horizon
is even more
ukraine matina
martina you have the floor
for speak
hi
thank you thank you
can you hear me okay
sorry
yes great um there's also word that
moldova and georgia intend to submit
applications for membership
um
would you mind uh letting us know if
that's already happened um and
could we just get a a broader comment on
this sort of
push for eastward expansion
um in this
moment and uh
and how potentially this impacts
candidate
countries that have been
waiting for quite a while
thank you matina um well i'm sure that
once once those countries do submit
formal either application
um
we will all be
informed of this and you as well but of
course if we do get the information we
will pass it on
i would not describe this come on on
stage as an eastward as a push for
eastern expansion by the european union
these are countries um
that are expressing a wish to join the
european union which actually shows the
success
of the european union as a
pro as a project for peace
and for prosperity um so it is obviously
welcome that others see the european
union as a successful model and um and
want to and want to join us and
it is clear that this is a result of the
success
of this project uh over the past uh
seven um seven decades now on the
specifics of requests anna have we
reached any updates um no uh fortunately
i am not in a position to confirm
anything um you know that um how this
works is actually um the applications
for your membership are submitted to the
council in concrete to the rotating
presidency that then transmits it to the
secretariat of the council so in essence
to the council um of course i understand
that everybody else receives courtesy
copies but again the formal uh
submission is to the council um as eric
said i think that once and if this
arrives then we will be in a position to
uh to to to to say more
um maybe just a general point um you
know on what you were mentioning
expansion to the east or not i think
that um you know the european union um
has always recognized that of course um
you know every country has the right to
choose uh its own destiny and to decide
its um its foreign policy and i think
that um
you know also the european leaders um
have always recognized as well and
acknowledged the european aspirations
and um the european choice of uh ukraine
uh the republic of moldova in georgia
and georgia
and we understand of course the
importance um of the step for the
ukrainian people and also of course as
well as for the people of moldova and
georgia who wish to be part of the eu
and as eric has very well expressed and
explained there is a process
and
in the case of ukraine this process has
been set in motion and it will be now of
course up for discussion uh for the
european council
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
mariah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
immediate
[Music]
peter peter peter thompson you have the
floor
oh
um
i forgot sorry peter i forgot the second
question on humanitarian aid
from from maria so
we will take this and then we will come
to you
is
[Music]
um
um
peter we come back to you
thank you eric thanks for taking my
question um
i apologize if it's been addressed
earlier in the briefing i came in a bit
late my question is relating to further
sanctions
uh transport and especially the closing
reports has been talked about in a few
member states over the last days after
the closing of of airspaces
my question is is is this something
that's expected by uh by by the high
representative to be discussed in the
coming days and and the [ __ ] meeting
tomorrow i hope you can uh elaborate a
bit on that thank you
thank you nebila
do you hear the question
the question is whether the fact will
discuss sanctions related to transport
in particular maritime
oops
hi hi peter no not to my information
this is not part of the discussions in
the fac as you know the hrvp has called
foreign fac tomorrow uh where there will
be
as invited uh
secretary of state anthony blinken and
also secretary
also secretary general of nato
stoltenberg and
foreign minister of canada and of the uk
thank you i think more generally what we
can say is that obviously uh the
commission continues to monitor the
situation
um on the ground uh very very carefully
uh and that we will make all proposals
as required dan already mentioned one
area in which
this is explicitly a possibility which
is the area of banks to be excluded from
from swift
everything is on the table as the
president has said
many times before the outbreak of um of
the invasion and therefore everything
remains
on the table
we are adjusting our response
we have taken strong measures from the
beginning strengthen them further and
will continue to adapt as our response
as events on the ground require
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
what does it take for for the commission
to include shutter in the categories of
oligarchs also being
an eu citizen
second i'm kind of confused about uh the
financial sanctions and the blocking of
swift
can anybody explain to me
the eu companies who are importing from
energy to everything else from
russia
which kind of system banking system and
to which banks they are standing their
money as we speak
in in russia
and a third question for for for anna
[Music]
does the commission is is building up
its ideas
how many questions should the
questionnaire
[Music]
uh or expect it to contain uh uh
to be sent to ukrainian authorities i
recall that bosnia for example had
more than 3 000 questions
and and and when the the
commission is expected to be dated by by
the council to to make those uh prepare
the questionnaire is the commission
ready to offer
a specific technical help
to speed up the the response for the
question of concerning the circumstances
we are now
thank you
um
on your second and your third question
the second question on
which channels
companies importing products including
energy
from
russia are
using
to make the payments i would
i would say that this is not something
that we
are in charge of you need to contact
the companies and check
with them please
on
ukraine enlargement look i can i've been
extremely clear
extremely clear
the president has said
that
this is a question which
should be discussed at the highest level
by leaders so you know you're asking us
uh very detailed technical questions
that
basically assume that um i haven't said
anything here on the podium there is a
prerequisite now which is and i think
that's entirely normal a uh discussion
at the highest political uh political
level
um on um your question on um
on further sanctions against
personalities as you know we never ever
comment uh on um on the sanctioned
proposals that we make before uh before
are tabled and we will certainly
stick to
this practice
right david you have
another question
so a follow-up to for johannes perhaps
you didn't see my hand at the time um
so uh
it was mentioned that this
ban on russian media
was temporary i would like to know what
is the
length of the temporary ban
um and how that relates to the
the clause 11 article 11. and secondly
what criteria are now being used to
create a ban on media
when there was a war with georgia there
was no such thing and there's been
you know major wars around the world
world
occupation of tibet weaker problem gulf
problem wars in africa so what is a
specific uh criteria that would which is
being applied in this case thank you
thank you johannes
yes thank you for the follow-up question
so the sanctions
against russia today and sputnik are
time limited
it's very important
and i can quote from from the regulation
was adopted by the member states
the measure should be maintained until
the aggression against ukraine is put to
an end
and until the russian federation and its
associated media outlets cease to
conduct propaganda actions against the
union and its member states
so um this will be then for the council
to determine when these measures would
end
um i think that's what i have to say on
this yeah there was a second question on
the criteria
used for the occlusion scope as opposed
to previous
conflicts or conflicts elsewhere
i think i have already uh quoted earlier
from the from the um from decision i can
maybe recall the rational behind these
sanctions that were
adopted um
the measures target the core of the
disinformation in the question machine
russia today rt and sputnik
including various linguistic versions
these outlets are directly controlled
and operated by the russian state
operators and are not editorially
independent
they have been manipulating information
in a systematic campaign to destabilize
the situation in ukraine
in the neighborhood of ukraine and to
and across europe
um
and
this is the reason why why they were
sanctioned so this is it's very
important to recall that this is not
about censorship this is about a
sanction
and
yeah i think um
in
so this is not maybe i can
expect further on it so this is not
about opinions being censored but this
is about an instrument this is used as
uh
an instrument in this war as information
warfare
and in a coordinated manner in this
context
and
and i can recall what i said earlier
already that russia today and sputnik
are and they quote essentially
instrumental in bringing forward and
supporting russia's aggression against
ukraine so that is the reasoning
yeah thank you david i'm uh i'm we're
not going to engage into a debate um on
this uh
and
here uh
you have already had uh the opportunity
to request uh
answers from us on this on this issue um
there is
a decision by the european union
we are
a union that is governed by the rule of
law hence decisions can be contested by
those that
are targeted
by them um and therefore
this is not some sort of um
this is not some sort of definitive
ban
that would apply without
any
any sort of protection mechanism
and therefore
you know we believe that the ground the
grounds that have been given in the
decision
are extremely clear
justify why we believe that it was
timely and proportionate
to act against
two outlets which are operating as
propaganda operators of the kremlin and
this in this conflict and i stress in
this conflict
and as johannes has set out
these are time limited in the sense that
they are related to the actions by
russia so that is all that we have to
say on the on the issue you can also of
course always follow up
bilaterally
federica
we can't hear you federica
um can you hear me now yeah go ahead
hello yes
okay i have a question on on poland um i
would like to know now that uh um poland
is raised up to the expectations um
and providing support to migrants and
becoming uh a hero in this situation
um and since we are considering uh more
funds besides the recovery funds to uh
give out give out to the states in
european states in need during this
situation i would like to understand
what is going to be the future of the
recovery plan uh for uh poland if the
commission is thinking to change its
mind
if it's not
given the fact that nothing internally
in poland has changed on the front of
the respect of the rule of law so just
an update on that and what you're
thinking thank you so much
thank you very felika the answer is very
simple as
i said in my previous answer we are an
organization that is governed by laws
and regulations and there is
a very specific regulation that applies
to the criteria that have to be met
by the member states in order for us to
be able to make a positive
recommendation when it comes to the
adoption of the recovery and resilience
facility
plans of these
of these member states
and that situation has absolutely not
changed we continue to be engaged in
discussions uh with the polish
authorities on
their uh on their national plan and
we'll update you once there is news
on this issue but today we have nothing
new to report on this
right
i see no further hand
raised so i thank you very much for your
participation and i will see you
tomorrow
we will see you tomorrow
so